hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the arrow dodge red light
green light challenge thing we just made
it up while we're here because we had
these bows nerf bows that we're gonna
shoot each other with and they're gonna
be over there and they are gonna be
trying to dodge my arrows every time I
fire an arrow they can take one step
forward as far as they want but then
they have to freeze it and then try to
dodge my arrow again and they can move
and pivot but they have to keep one foot
planted where they were and I can't go
past this line and their objective is to
cross that blue line up there whoever
gets there first wins ready here we go
you guys ready you can't reach across
the line your last one should be at the
line
oh this is so close all right we're
gonna change to tur scuzz it's too easy
for people to get to the end so this
time he wants to do where you guys are
constantly moving heel to toe but we can
wail on you you can stop and dodge where
you can keep moving heel to toe but you
can only move forward heel to toe did
you intentionally over bad at this
I dine on your game so fast ready shots
I'm Susan Gary Oh
like half way to play